witnesses described the explosion as
extremely powerful 30 tonnes of chlorine
gas created a thick yellow cloud the
force of the blast scattering workers
and moored vehicles around the dark
maui's score was in the crane he's
wounded but lucky to have survived
i was inside the crane and i heard the
sound of an explosion a very loud
explosion
i came out from the crane towards the
ship and just before i reached the ship
i saw this yellow material i didn't know
that it was toxic i thought the ship had
exploded
this ship is
supposed to be heading to djibouti and
about 5 25
a month time of jordan time
this accident happened exactly what
happened it's not clear but some uh
something happened that burst the
container that had this chlorine and it
spread out to people in the area killing
and injuring many people and most in
jordan is there also other nationals
apparently among those who are dead and
injured
emergency workers put a 500 meter cordon
around the site surrounding areas where
evacuated and people instructed to stay
indoors
authorities say 2 700 security and
emergency personnel were sent to the
scene dozens of them sustained injuries
during the rescue operation
hundreds of wounded people were rushed
to hospitals
some of them to intensive care units or
icus
the emergency room department dealt with
the casualties some of them were put on
respirators some of them were
transferred to the icus and all of the
medical staff were available and people
also came from outside to help us
authorities say the nearest residential
areas are 25 kilometers away and weren't
affected many people in the area want to
know how the incident happened and
whether it could affect their health
jordanian authorities say they will
launch an investigation to find out
muhammad al jazeera